Katrina: 醒一醒
Katrina: Wake up.
Katrina: 哼哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 危险数据真的是
Katrina: Dangerous data, seriously.
Shure: 小朋友们切勿模仿
Shure: Kids, don't try this at home.
Shure的女友:不是下雨了
Shure's GF: Is it raining?
Shure的女友:他那个包上面有块电子屏啊
Shure's GF: There's an electronic screen on his bag.
Shure的女友:防水
Shure's GF: Waterproof.
Shure: 应该吧
Shure: Probably.
Shure的女友:应该吧
Shure's GF: Probably.
Katrina: 我衣服还在楼下
Katrina: My clothes are still downstairs.
Katrina: 呃 小猫咪
Katrina: Uh, little kitty.
Katrina: 嗨
Katrina: Hi.
Katrina: 喵
Katrina: Meow.
Katrina:  Lucia Lucia
Katrina: Lucia, Lucia.
Katrina: 那外面好像下雨了
Katrina: It looks like it's raining outside.
Katrina: 你要把裤子收回来
Katrina: You should bring your pants in.
Lucia:噢 ok 谢谢
Lucia: Oh, okay, thanks.
Katrina: 你看你要走了
Katrina: Look, you're leaving.
Katrina: 老天都下雨了
Katrina: Even the sky is crying.
Katrina: 哎小猫咪又来了
Katrina: Oh, the little kitty is back.
Katrina: 他刚看着我跑了
Katrina: He just ran off after looking at me.
Katrina: 你看它又跑
Katrina: Look, he ran again.
Jake:给他他吃瓜
Jake: Give him some melon.
Jake:可以吃瓜对吧
Jake: He can eat melon, right?
Jake:给他点瓜皮
Jake: Give him some rind.
Katrina: 这好像就是
Katrina: It seems like...
Katrina: 感觉他在观察人类
Katrina: It feels like he's observing humans.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 又走了
Katrina: He's gone again.
Jake:不下了
Jake: It's not raining.
Shure: 不下了
Shure: It's not raining.
Shure: 看错了对不起
Shure: I was mistaken, sorry.
Shure: 不下了吧
Shure: It's not raining, right?
Jake:一会儿刮彩票吗
Jake: Are we scratching tickets later?
Jake:谢谢你 不知道
Jake: Thank you, not sure.
Jake:修硕说停
Jake: Shure says it's stopped.
Katrina: 今天晚上有啥安排吗
Katrina: Any plans for tonight?
Katrina: 你们下午干了什么
Katrina: What did you do this afternoon?
Katrina: 拆今天晚上拆屋子
Katrina: Tearing down the house tonight.
Jake:对就是给你打包嘛
Jake: Yeah, packing it up for you.
Shure: 还有半个瓜在楼上
Shure: There's still half a melon upstairs.
Shure: 然后你们想吃的话记得切着吃
Shure: If you want to eat it, remember to cut it.
Shure: 最后教再交代两句
Shure: Lastly, let me say a couple more things.
Katrina: 那这些东西怎么办呀
Katrina: What about these things?
Tasha:所以你们走
Tasha: So you guys are leaving?
Tasha:你们回去
Tasha: Are you going back?
Tasha:回去了吗
Tasha: Going back?
Shure: 对我们准备回去了直接
Shure: Yeah, we're getting ready to go back directly.
Jake:就刷一刷
Jake: Just give it a wash.
Jake:比如说那个盘子吗
Jake: Like that plate, for example.
Katrina: 我说这些没有用完的
Katrina: I mean, these that aren't used up.
Jake:这些放哪呢
Jake: Where do we put these?
Katrina: 你带回去吗
Katrina: Are you taking them back?
Jake:嗯你想带走就带走
Jake: Yeah, if you want to take them, take them.
Katrina: 感觉扔掉好浪费啊
Katrina: It feels like such a waste to throw them away.
Jake:是的是呀
Jake: Yeah, it is.
Tasha:带回去我在学校也没法做呀
Tasha: If I take them back, I can't use them at school.
Jake:好说
Jake: Fair enough.
Jake:卖掉
Jake: Sell them.
Tasha:卖掉
Tasha: Sell them.
Tasha:你卖分我一半就行
Tasha: If you sell them, just give me half.
Jake:为什么
Jake: Why?
Tasha:哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Tasha:可是他要两他两包起卖
Tasha: But he wants to sell them in packs of two.
Tasha:两包好像才5块钱
Tasha: Two packs for only 5 bucks.
Katrina: 主要是卖给谁啊
Katrina: Who are we going to sell them to?
Lucia:就是没拆的
Lucia: Only the unopened ones.
Lucia:我们可以比如说大家装一下
Lucia: We could pack them, for example.
Lucia:拆了的就不太好带或者
Lucia: The opened ones are harder to take.
Tasha:玉米淀粉
Tasha: Cornstarch.
Tasha:做汤可能会用到
Tasha: Might use it to make soup.
Tasha:寄给我妈吧
Tasha: I'll send it to my mom.
Katrina: 哦他这能寄快递
Katrina: Oh, can they deliver it?
Katrina: 能上门取件吗
Katrina: Can they pick it up?
Jake:对这个可以
Jake: Yeah, they can.
Katrina: 哦 那今天晚上让他上门取
Katrina: Oh, then let's have them pick it up tonight.
Katrina: 柯欣呢
Katrina: Where's Kexin?
Tasha:噜噜噜在房间里
Tasha: Lulu is in the room.
Tasha:他们居然啊
Tasha: Can't believe it.
Katrina: 他们怎么了
Katrina: What happened to them?
Shure: 再见
Shure: Bye.
Katrina: 哦原来退伍啊
Katrina: Oh, so you're retiring.
Katrina: 你去把那个放下
Katrina: You go put that down.
Katrina: 把骏马放下
Katrina: Put the horse down.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 立正 嗖习
Shure: Attention! Salute!
Jake:我们应该列队
Jake: We should line up.
Lucia:拎个枪什么的吗
Lucia: Are we carrying guns or something?
Jake:枪毙是吧
Jake: Execution, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia:不是
Lucia: No.
Jake:我们第一位叛徒哈哈
Jake: Our first traitor, haha.
Katrina: 明早啥时候退房啊
Katrina: What time are we checking out tomorrow morning?
Lucia:12点
Lucia: 12 o'clock.
Katrina: 我们早上
Katrina: So in the morning...
Katrina: 自己想什么时候走就什么时候走吗
Katrina: We can leave whenever we want?
Katrina: 还是
Katrina: Or...
Jake:对啊对啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:12点退房吗
Jake: Check out at 12?
Shure: 他们那个刘帅和XBZ是开车来的吗
Shure: Did Choiszt and XBZ drive here?
Jake:刘帅也来
Jake: Choiszt is coming too.
Shure: 刘帅来吗
Shure: Choiszt is coming?
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Lucia:那一会是要过来吗
Lucia: Is he coming over later?
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake:XBZ要来
Jake: XBZ is coming.
Shure: 谢彬竹要来
Shure: Xie Binzhu is coming.
Shure: 让他明天帮我把把行礼带回去
Shure: Ask him to help take my luggage back tomorrow.
Jake:他太惨了
Jake: He's too miserable.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Lucia:他不是还发烧呢吗
Lucia: Isn't he still having a fever?
Shure: 他没死就行
Shure: As long as he's not dead.
Tasha: 哈哈哈 这个话记住了
Tasha: Hahaha, remember that.
Lucia:救命
Lucia: Help!
Katrina: 兄弟情
Katrina: Brotherhood.
Jake:别以为你自己不戴眼镜就
Jake: Don't think that just because you don't wear glasses...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:好你思念啥
Jake: So, what are you missing?
Lucia: 对啊 你北京本地
Lucia: Yeah, you're local in Beijing.
Katrina: 顺点东西走吧
Katrina: Take some things with you as you go.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah
Shure: 是不是充电宝哈哈哈
Shure: Is it a power bank? Hahaha
Jake:充充电宝
Jake: Charging the power bank
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Katrina: 可以顺充电宝吧
Katrina: Can we charge the power bank?
Katrina: 我正好缺一个
Katrina: I happen to need one.
Lucia:我也
Lucia: Me too.
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Lucia:我们明天走出去
Lucia: We'll walk out tomorrow
Lucia:把自己用的这个充电宝给他顺走
Lucia: And take the power bank we've been using
Shure: 还有一个我
Shure: And there's one for me too
Katrina: 你要不要带点鸡蛋回去
Katrina: Do you want to take some eggs back?
Tasha:是这个吗
Tasha: Is it this one?
Tasha:这有个黑的
Tasha: There's a black one here
Tasha:哦 算了那就不是
Tasha: Oh, never mind, that's not it
Shure: 有一个大的
Shure: There's a big one
Katrina: 你端一盒鸡蛋回去吧修硕
Katrina: Shure, you should take a box of eggs home
Lucia:对刚好你在北京这个不容易散
Lucia: Yeah, it's perfect since you're in Beijing, they won't break easily
Katrina: 补点营养
Katrina: Get some nutrition
Katrina: 还有你的咸鸭蛋
Katrina: And your salted duck eggs
Tasha:带
Tasha: Bring them
Shure: 哦 还有咸鸭蛋
Shure: Oh, salted duck eggs too
Shure: 那箱子不好使
Shure: That box isn't usable
Katrina: 还有酒
Katrina: And wine
Shure: 我ipad 还没放时去
Shure: My iPad isn't packed yet
Shure: 酒我带了一瓶
Shure: I already brought a bottle of wine
Katrina: 好家伙
Katrina: Oh wow
Katrina: 瓜分
Katrina: Divide it up
Shure: 哦对杨老板还有报销账单我没领
Shure: Oh right, Jake, I haven't received the reimbursement
Tasha:杨老板什么时候结
Tasha: Jake, when will you settle it?
Tasha:我的也没报呢
Tasha: I haven't submitted mine either
Shure: 我们临走前把钱款两清
Shure: Let's clear the accounts before we leave
Katrina:  哈哈今今晚算账是吧
Katrina: Haha, are we settling accounts tonight?
Shure: 不当面结清
Shure: Not face to face
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Katrina: 你买了啥呀
Katrina: What did you buy?
Katrina: 他屋子好像也没买啥
Katrina: He doesn't seem to have bought much
Shure: 我屋子里没买啥
Shure: I didn't buy much for my room
Shure: 我吃饭点了
Shure: I ordered food
Katrina: 你帮我点
Katrina: Help me order
Katrina: 点外卖了是吗
Shure: 来帮我摁个计算器家人们
Tasha:你等会帮我也摁一下
Shure: 好的
Tasha:算了你报吧
Tasha:我来帮你加
Shure: 首先139块8
Tasha:139.8
Shure的女友:点8也要算进来
Shure: 去加94
Katrina: 没有 四舍五四舍算客气了
Jake:99哈哈
Tasha:94
Tasha:加
Shure: 22块5毛7
Tasha:22.5毛7
Jake:哈哈哈
Lucia:那个7
Shure: 加40.8
Tasha:40.8
Shure: 加96
Tasha:96
Shure: 加49块5毛2
Tasha:49.5毛2
Tasha:442.69
Shure: 然后还有等一下
Jake:还有摸个0吧
Jake:40 哈哈哈
Jake:摸个0 40 哈哈哈
Tasha:你怎么不说0.69嘞
Tasha:摸个头吧
Shure: 看看这就是资本主义的压榨
Shure: 家人们我们要
Tasha:警惕
Tasha:我都不敢把我的账单发给他看了
Lucia:我也
Katrina: 我的好长
Tasha:我这有2,000多的账要报
Shure: 啊34块9毛8
Tasha:34.9毛8
Shure: 还有一个咖啡豆钱
Shure: And there's also the coffee bean money.
Tasha:咖啡豆
Tasha: Coffee beans?
Shure: 咖啡豆是
Shure: Coffee beans are...
Lucia:我觉得我们天天在这演群口相声
Lucia: I feel like we're doing a group comedy show every day.
Shure: 148
Shure: 148.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha:148的咖啡豆
Tasha: 148 for coffee beans?
Jake:这么整呢
Jake: How are we doing this?
Jake:假的吧
Jake: Is it fake?
Shure: 嗯是真的
Shure: No, it's real.
Shure: 它两包起卖主要是
Shure: They sell it in packs of two mainly.
Jake:总共这么多钱
Jake: All this money?
Jake:对 好 你是谁
Jake: Okay, who are you?
Shure: 我是哈哈哈
Shure: I'm... hahaha.
Shure: 没事咱咱扫码就行
Shure: Don't worry, we can just scan the code.
Tasha:哈哈哈哦
Tasha: Hahaha, oh.
Tasha:来帮我加一下
Tasha: Come help me add this.
Jake:等会等会
Jake: Wait, wait.
Jake:多少钱 625点
Jake: How much? 625, right?
Katrina: 我还没算呢
Katrina: I haven't calculated it yet.
Shure: 哎 摸个零吧
Shure: Let's round it.
Shure: 625就行了
Shure: 625 is fine.
Jake:哎
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 大方吗杨老板
Shure: Generous, aren't you, Jake?
Jake:哎是挺好
Jake: Yeah, it's quite good.
Shure: 给你省了1/100新币 哈哈哈
Shure: I saved you 1/100 of a new dollar. Hahaha.
Shure: ok
Shure: Ok.
Tasha:你怎么不帮我啊
Tasha: Why don't you help me?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Tasha:我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Jake:来互摁是吧
Jake: Come on, let's press it together.
Shure: ok
Shure: Ok.
Jake:来 摁一下
Jake: Come on, press it.
Tasha:烤箱30
Tasha: Oven 30.
Lucia:你看这就是单次博弈的坏处
Lucia: See, this is the downside of single-play games.
Lucia:你们俩要是经常互相摁的话
Lucia: If you two pressed each other often...
Lucia:双方就会
Lucia: Then both sides would...
Jake:啊就有默契是吧
Jake: Ah, you'd get a mutual understanding, right?
Lucia:不是开始胡说八道了
Lucia: No, that's nonsense.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Right, right.
Tasha:30烤箱加24跑腿
Tasha: 30 for the oven and 24 for delivery
Shure: 24
Tasha:装修房间493
Tasha: Renovating the room, 493
Shure: 496
Tasha:加25的地毯
Tasha: Plus 25 for the carpet
Shure: 25地毯钱
Shure: 25 for the carpet
Tasha:加达美乐点餐220
Tasha: Plus 220 for Domino's order
Shure: 220加
Shure: 220 added
Tasha:跑腿16
Tasha: Delivery 16
Shure: 16加
Shure: 16 added
薇:盒马702
Violet: Hema 702
Shure: 哈哈 哦
Shure: Haha, oh
Jake:我草哈哈哈
Jake: Wow, hahaha
Shure: 噢你
Shure: Oh, you
Katrina: 噢盒马
Katrina: Oh, Hema
Shure: 都让人家付的
Shure: All paid by them
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes
Tasha:厨房用纸10块
Tasha: Kitchen paper 10
Shure: 10块
Shure: 10
Tasha:夹板20
Tasha: Plywood 20
Shure: 20
Tasha:蛋奶油55
Tasha: Egg cream 55
Shure: 55
Tasha:低筋面粉7
Tasha: Low-gluten flour 7
Shure: 7
Tasha:啊
Tasha: Ah
Tasha:麦当劳568
Tasha: McDonald's 568
Shure: 568的麦当劳
Shure: 568 for McDonald's
Katrina: 麦当劳也是你点的
Katrina: You ordered McDonald's too
Tasha:跑腿12.6
Tasha: Delivery 12.6
Tasha:跑腿15
Tasha: Delivery 15
Tasha:昨天的披萨点餐169今天中午的饭
Tasha: Yesterday's pizza order 169, today's lunch
Tasha:说吧
Tasha: Say it
Shure: 2,366块6
Shure: 2,366.6
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow
Shure: 没没算错吧应该
Shure: Didn't miscalculate, right?
Tasha:不知道你啊
Tasha: Don't know, you
Tasha:你不要坑我
Tasha: Don't mess with me
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:你你你坑的不一定是你吧
Jake: The one you're messing with might not be you
Shure: 哈哈哈我再再来一次
Shure: Hahaha, let me try again.
Shure: 再来一次
Shure: One more time.
Shure: 我怕
Shure: I'm scared.
Tasha:烤箱30
Tasha: Oven, 30.
Shure: 30
Shure: 30.
Tasha:跑腿24
Tasha: Errand, 24.
Shure: 24
Shure: 24.
Tasha:装饰房间493
Tasha: Room decor, 493.
Shure: 493
Shure: 493.
Katrina: 咱不需要给他贴那个订单截图吗
Katrina: Shouldn't we attach the order screenshot?
Tasha:地毯25
Tasha: Carpet, 25.
Shure: 25
Shure: 25.
Tasha:达美乐220 跑腿16
Tasha: Domino's, 220. Errand, 16.
Tasha:盒马702 厨房用纸10块 夹板20
Tasha: Hema, 702. Kitchen paper, 10. Clipboard, 20.
Tasha:淡奶油55
Tasha: Heavy cream, 55.
Tasha:低筋面粉 7
Tasha: Low-gluten flour, 7.
Lucia:对我在想我装修的那个
Lucia: Yeah, I'm thinking about my renovation.
Tasha:麦当劳568
Tasha: McDonald's, 568.
Katrina: 累了
Katrina: Tired.
Tasha:跑腿12.6
Tasha: Errand, 12.6.
Katrina: 装修那有很多零零碎碎的
Katrina: Renovation has so many little things.
Tasha:昨天的跑腿15
Tasha: Yesterday's errand, 15.
Katrina: 反正500肯定拉满了我
Katrina: Anyway, 500 for sure.
Tasha:今天中午点餐169
Tasha: Today's lunch order, 169.
Lucia:我之前算了
Lucia: I calculated before.
Lucia:我好像没到
Lucia: I don't think I reached it.
Shure: 两遍都是2366
Shure: Both times, it's 2366.
Lucia:不过过快了
Lucia: But it's too fast.
Jake:两遍都是啊
Jake: Both times, huh?
Jake:行多少
Jake: Okay, how much?
Shure: 3 2366.6
Shure: 3, 2366.6.
Jake:来来来扫扫扫
Jake: Come on, scan, scan, scan.
Tasha:你也扫啊
Tasha: You scan too.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha:谢谢你杨老板
Tasha: Thank you, Jake.
Katrina: 吃大餐去吧
Katrina: Let's go for a big meal.
Tasha:还写什么论文呀
Tasha: Why write a thesis?
Jake:写什么论文吃大餐
Jake: Write a thesis? Let's have a big meal.
Jake:大餐去了
Jake: Big meal it is.
Katrina: 吃大餐去吧
Katrina: Let's go have a big meal.
Katrina: 哈哈带人家吃点好的
Katrina: Haha, let's go eat something good.
Tasha:哇
Tasha: Wow.
Jake:哎多多少
Jake: Hey, how much?
Jake:2,000
Jake: 2,000.
Shure: 366块6
Shure: 366.6.
Jake:366 好
Jake: 366, okay.
Jake:2300
Jake: 2,300.
Tasha:什么
Tasha: What?
Tasha:呃还少带了一个6
Tasha: Uh, you missed a 6.
Tasha:好开始
Tasha: Okay, start.
Tasha:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahaha.
Tasha:杨老板到底转了多少
Tasha: How much did Jake actually spin?
Tasha:可恶啊哈哈
Tasha: So annoying, haha.
Tasha:他怎么把0加点加上了
Tasha: How did he add the decimal point?
Tasha:好吧
Tasha: Alright.
Jake:不应该加上吗
Jake: Shouldn't it be added?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:我还缺啥吗
Jake: Am I missing anything?
Tasha:其实我觉得可以加
Tasha: Actually, I think it can be added.
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:加什么
Jake: Add what?
Tasha:加上那个点
Tasha: Add the decimal point.
Jake:再加6分钱是吧
Jake: Add another 6 cents, right?
Shure: 对我的充电宝
Shure: Yeah, my power bank.
Katrina: 充电宝还分人吗
Katrina: Power banks are assigned to people?
Katrina: 我们不都随便拿
Katrina: Don't we just grab any?
Shure: 不是我有一个自带的充电宝
Shure: No, I have my own power bank.
Katrina: 哦哦哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh.
Jake:你还损失了一个充电宝
Jake: You even lost a power bank.
Tasha:哇
Tasha: Wow.
Tasha:算上你这笔钱
Tasha: Count that in your expenses.
Tasha:我这个什么微信收款
Tasha: My WeChat payments.
Tasha:累积到1万块钱了
Tasha: Have accumulated to 10,000 yuan.
Jake:哦这么真
Jake: Oh, really?
Shure: 然后还有还有什么吗
Shure: And is there anything else?
Tasha:好我的报销完毕
Tasha: Okay, my reimbursements are done.
Shure: 这几天的工资没有谈
Shure: We haven't talked about the wages for these days.
Jake:哈哈哈好嘞
Jake: Hahaha, alright.
Jake:你你找找你的充电宝
Jake: You, you find your power bank.
Jake:你你找找
Jake: You, you look for it.
Jake:对总共就两层
Jake: Yes, there are only two layers in total.
Shure: 啊这个是我的啊
Shure: Ah, this is mine.
Jake:给他换给他换一个
Jake: Change it for him, change it for him.
Katrina: 算上今天
Katrina: Including today.
Jake:对欠4天
Jake: Yes, owe 4 days.
Jake:欠4天工资
Jake: Owe 4 days of wages.
Jake:然后你你红包抢过吗
Jake: And you, have you ever grabbed red envelopes?
Tasha:欠4天工资
Tasha: Owe 4 days of wages.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha:那我一天没领
Tasha: Then I didn't get one day.
Jake:你不你第一天抢的红包啊
Jake: You didn't, you got the red envelope on the first day.
Shure: 啊昨天我看一下
Shure: Ah, let me check yesterday.
Tasha:是吗
Tasha: Really?
Tasha:到底是从哪天开始算
Tasha: When exactly did it start counting from?
Katrina: 我好像
Katrina: I seem to...
Katrina: 但是我领过一个这种
Katrina: But I got one like this.
Katrina: 70的这种
Katrina: One of these 70 ones.
Katrina: 哦我这还有昨天超市的账我去
Katrina: Oh, I still have the supermarket bill from yesterday, I'll go...
Jake:来来来我给你给你算算
Jake: Come, come, let me calculate for you.
Lucia:这瓜还挺好吃啊
Lucia: This melon is pretty tasty.
Tasha:我也觉的
Tasha: I think so too.
Lucia:非常的
Lucia: Very...
Katrina: 我抢了161
Katrina: I grabbed 161.
Katrina: 我靠我抢了3
Katrina: Oh my, I grabbed 3.
Jake:应该是从
Jake: It should be from...
Jake:差点就忘了
Jake: Almost forgot.
Jake:就这个300
Jake: It's this 300.
Jake:第第一天300是吧
Jake: The first day was 300, right?
Jake:嗯然后第二天157 这算吗
Jake: Mm, and the second day was 157, does that count?
Jake:什么嗯
Jake: What, mm.
Jake:哎你143领掉了别的应该没有什么
Jake: Hey, you used up 143, there shouldn't be anything else.
Katrina: 哼
Katrina: Hmph.
Jake:哎还有这个153领掉了是吧
Jake: Hey, and you used up this 153, right?
Jake:604 好来扫你
Jake: 604, okay, let me scan you.
Shure: 感谢老板
Shure: Thanks, boss.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Tasha:904这是什么
Tasha: 904, what's this?
Shure: 提供打车
Shure: For the ride.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:这是
Jake: Here it is.
Katrina: 祝大哥顺顺顺什么
Katrina: Wishing big brother all the best in everything.
Jake:三 四天 四天的工资
Jake: Three, four days, four days' wages.
Katrina: 顺水
Katrina: Smooth sailing.
Tasha:钱 怎么还有4块呢
Tasha: Money, why is there still 4 bucks?
Jake:因为他之前摸了个红包
Jake: Because he got a red envelope earlier.
Shure: 顺山顺水顺财神
Shure: Smooth mountains, smooth waters, smooth wealth.
Katrina: 顺顺顺顺顺财神
Katrina: Smooth, smooth, smooth, smooth wealth.
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:啥东西啊
Jake: What's that?
Shure: 哦我有钱有钱了
Shure: Oh, I have money now.
Jake:有钱了
Jake: Got money now.
Shure: 现在有好多钱
Shure: Now I have a lot of money.
Shure: 再见了杨老板
Shure: Goodbye, Jake.
Shure: 我会想念你的
Shure: I'll miss you.
Shure的女友:没关系这全是我的
Shure's GF: It's okay, it's all mine.
Katrina: 你们俩咋回去
Katrina: How are you two getting back?
Katrina: 打车还是什么
Katrina: By taxi or what?
Shure: 打车 还是有点远打车回去
Shure: By taxi. It's a bit far, so we'll take a taxi back.
Katrina: 打车回去多少钱
Katrina: How much is the taxi fare?
Shure的女友:不知道好像
Shure's GF: Not sure, I think...
Katrina: 报哈哈哈
Katrina: Report, hahaha.
Shure: 这个报吗杨老板
Shure: Report this, Jake?
Jake:这个也能报
Jake: You can report this too.
Shure: 哎呀操打车
Shure: Oh man, taking a taxi.
Jake:你先打你先打你先打
Jake: You go ahead and call, you go first.
Shure: OK哎呦我的妈呀
Shure: OK, oh my gosh.
Jake:打完
Jake: Call done?
Katrina: 哇回武汉能报吗
Katrina: Wow, can we report the fare back to Wuhan?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:打车回武汉是吗
Jake: Taking a taxi back to Wuhan?
Lucia:哦那我打车回家
Lucia: Oh, then I'll take a taxi home.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina: 打车
Katrina: Take a taxi.
Tasha:那我打车回个家
Tasha: Then I'll take a taxi home.
Jake:回哪杭州啊
Jake: To where? Hangzhou?
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Lucia:要打车回三亚
Lucia: Need to take a taxi to Sanya.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 我我们把杨老板给榨干了
Shure: We totally drained Jake.
Jake:哈对又惦记又没钱了
Jake: Yeah, thinking about it again, and I'm out of money.
Alice:什么打车回三亚
Alice: What, taking a taxi back to Sanya?
Lucia:嗯 对
Lucia: Mm, yes.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm.
Alice:打车回三亚
Alice: Taking a taxi back to Sanya?
Lucia:我 没有没有开玩笑
Lucia: I'm not joking.
Tasha:他说打车报销
Tasha: He said the taxi fare will be reimbursed.
Alice:什么时候搭车
Alice: When are we taking the taxi?
Tasha:现在啊
Tasha: Right now.
Jake:明 啊 现在
Jake: Yeah, right now.
Alice:谁走啊
Alice: Who's leaving?
Jake:他走
Jake: He's leaving.
Alice:我也得走
Alice: I need to go too.
Shure: 杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Lucia:修硕
Lucia: Shure.
Shure: 我还第一天长安街的半天的工资
Shure: I still have half a day's wages from Chang'an Street.
Jake:哎
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 那个算吗
Shure: Does that count?
Jake:第一天
Jake: The first day?
Shure: 去长安街录像的那个
Shure: The day we filmed on Chang'an Street.
Jake:哎那应该
Jake: Oh, that should...
Shure: XBZ没给我
Shure: XBZ didn't give it to me.
Katrina: 私吞了
Katrina: He pocketed it.
Alice:什么叫把谢老板
Alice: What do you mean by "drained Jake"?
Shure: 给谢彬竹发了
Shure: He gave it to Xie Binzhu.
Alice:什么榨干
Alice: What do you mean "drained"?
Katrina: 杨杨老板
Katrina: Jake, Jake.
Katrina: 老板名字说怎么工资就别想要了
Katrina: If you say the boss's name, don't expect your salary.
Lucia:就是谢老板
Lucia: It's Mr. Crab.
Tasha:谢老板
Tasha: Mr. Xie.
Lucia:谢老板
Lucia: Mr. Crab.
Jake:谢老板我们做汉堡
Jake: Mr. Crab, we make burgers.
Tasha:卖汉堡的
Tasha: The burger seller.
Jake:哈哈哈 我们一起做汉堡去
Jake: Hahaha, let's make burgers together.
Shure: 130
Shure: 130.
Shure的女友:你打车了吗
Shure's GF: Did you get a taxi?
Shure: 138块5毛4
Shure: 138.54 yuan.
Alice:你们带伞了吗
Alice: Did you bring an umbrella?
Alice:只有这没下雨
Alice: It's not raining here.
Alice:朝阳都下了
Alice: But it's raining in Chaoyang.
Alice:要不拿出来
Alice: Should we take it out?
Katrina: 你今天晚上也要走啊
Katrina: Are you leaving tonight too?
Jake:等一下啊
Jake: Hold on a second.
Alice:啊对
Alice: Ah, right.
Jake:看一下
Jake: Let me check.
Katrina: 学校有事吗
Katrina: Do you have something at school?
Alice:对明天有事
Alice: Yeah, I have something tomorrow.
Alice:明天不想早起直接在寝室睡
Alice: I don't want to get up early, so I'll just sleep in the dorm.
Katrina: 真好
Katrina: That's nice.
Jake:第0天是150
Jake: Day 0 is 150.
Jake:你你说的是哪一个
Jake: Which one are you talking about?
Shure: 还负一天
Shure: There's even a negative one.
Shure: 你记不记得我提前拿到那个去长安街
Shure: Do you remember I got that thing early to go to Chang'an Street?
Shure: 跟那
Shure: And then...
Alice:所以现在在
Alice: So now it's...
Jake:那算150里啊
Jake: That's counted in the 150.
Shure: 那算这个
Shure: That counts for this.
Jake:对对对算150
Jake: Yes, yes, it counts for 150.
Katrina: 对对对算钱呢
Katrina: Yes, yes, it counts for the money.
Tasha:算工钱
Tasha: It counts as wages.
Katrina: 他问老板包工头要要清钱在这
Katrina: He asked the boss for the money here.
Shure: 那就报销一个打车费啦好吧
Shure: Then just reimburse a taxi fare, okay?
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Alice:哎我没戴眼镜
Alice: Oh, I didn't bring my glasses.
Shure: 谢谢老板谢谢老板
Shure: Thanks, boss, thanks.
Jake:别打专车就行
Jake: Just don't take a premium cab.
Shure: 没有没有没打专车没打专车
Shure: No, no, didn't take a premium cab.
Shure: 快车都没敢打
Shure: Didn't even take a fast one.
Shure: 咱打的是
Shure: We took a...
Tasha:拼车啊哈哈哈哈
Tasha: A carpool, haha.
Alice:呆会我打车能报销吗我比较近
Alice: Can I get reimbursed for my cab later? I'm pretty close.
Jake:都都可以
Jake: Yeah, yeah, no problem.
Jake:可以没问题
Jake: It's fine.
Alice:但我没戴眼镜我现在就要把它卸了
Alice: But I didn't bring my glasses, I need to take them off now.
Shure: 但是这个打车费有点贵
Shure: But this cab fare is a bit pricey.
Jake:什么你可以戴眼镜
Jake: What? You can wear glasses.
Shure: 能报眼镜呢
Shure: Can we get reimbursed for glasses?
Katrina: 多少钱多少钱多少钱
Katrina: How much, how much, how much?
Tasha:138块5毛4
Tasha: 138 yuan and 54 cents.
Katrina: 小声我以为两开头呢小声
Katrina: I thought it would be over 200.
Jake:100也也行吧
Jake: 100 is fine too.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Jake:好说
Jake: No problem.
Shure: 谢谢老板
Shure: Thanks, boss.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Alice:杨老板眼镜在哪
Alice: Jake, where are your glasses?
Shure: 今年啊顶会
Shure: This year at the conference...
Shure: 我感觉靖康的名字要要JKR
Shure: I feel like Jingkang's name will be JKR.
Shure: 这个名字要出现10-10 20次
Shure: This name will appear 10-20 times.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Alice:老板眼镜在哪
Alice: Boss, where are your glasses?
Tasha:无语哈哈哈无语
Tasha: Speechless, hahaha, speechless.
Lucia:我也不太了解
Lucia: I don't really know either.
Katrina: 算多
Katrina: It's a lot.
Katrina: 直接驳倒了
Katrina: Totally refuted.
Katrina: 我驳倒都没发生这么多
Katrina: Even my refutations weren't this many.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Shure: 院长了
Shure: Dean.
Shure: 哈哈哈杨院长
Shure: Hahaha, Dean Jake.
Tasha:受不了
Tasha: Can't take it.
Shure: 哎呦这个名字听着爽爽
Shure: Oh, this name sounds so cool.
Tasha:受不了啦
Tasha: Can't take it anymore.
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright.
Alice:所以眼镜在哪啊
Alice: So, where are the glasses?
Jake:你眼镜
Jake: Your glasses...
Katrina: 那我也来算账
Katrina: Let me do the math too.
Katrina: 我去拿我的笔点点
Katrina: I'll get my pen to count.
Alice:这个不是我的
Alice: This isn't mine.
Katrina: 点晚饭了吗
Katrina: Did you order dinner?
Jake:你眼镜在
Jake: Your glasses are...
Lucia:没呢
Lucia: Not yet.
Katrina: 感觉我还是没啥胃口
Katrina: I still don't have much of an appetite.
Alice:打完了吗
Alice: Did you finish?
Katrina: 吃点西瓜
Katrina: Have some watermelon.
Alice:我现在要开始拆喽
Alice: I'm going to start unwrapping now.
Katrina: 谢彬竹等一会来
Katrina: Xie Binzhu will come later.
Katrina: 谢彬竹说他要住住你的房间
Katrina: Xie Binzhu said he wants to stay in your room.
Tasha:XBZ让他吃完晚饭再来我们
Tasha: Let XBZ come after he finishes dinner.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice:XBZ晚上还来吗
Alice: Is XBZ coming tonight?
Tasha:他说他发烧了来换个床
Tasha: He said he has a fever and wants to change beds.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我说修硕走谁跟我玩
Katrina: Hahaha, I told Shure, "Who will play with me?"
Katrina: 他说他陪他过来唠嗑
Katrina: He said he'd come over to chat.
Alice:不是明天中午就结束吗
Alice: Isn't it ending by noon tomorrow?
Tasha:他说他过来唠
Tasha: He said he'd come over to chat.
Tasha:他说他过来唠嗑
Lucia:他来唠嗑
Lucia: He's coming to chat.
Katrina: 嗯他他们应该要帮忙拆东西
Katrina: Hmm, they probably need help taking things down.
Katrina: 董叉叉也问我们什么时候退房来着
Katrina: Jack also asked when we're checking out.
Alice:哦是拆这些
Alice: Oh, to take these down.
Katrina: 唠嗑指顺便
Katrina: Chatting just means casually.
Jake:不是谢彬竹
Jake: Isn't it Xie Binzhu?
Jake:谢彬竹他到底发不发烧啊
Jake: Is Xie Binzhu really having a fever or not?
Shure: 他发着 他确实是发着 发着
Shure: He has a fever. He really does, really does.
Jake:他发着就特适合聊天
Jake: Having a fever is perfect for chatting.
Tasha:他啊
Tasha: He is...
Tasha:他太想聊天了
Tasha: He really wants to chat.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Katrina: 他一直想套我的八卦你知道吗
Katrina: He always wants to gossip with me, you know?
Katrina: 昨天晚上没问完就走了
Katrina: Last night he left before finishing his questions.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure: 30 37度7还在外面坚持
Shure: 30, 37.7 degrees and still hanging outside.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Jake:这冷风中是吧 哈哈哈
Jake: In this cold wind, right? Hahaha
Shure: 他今天应该比昨天还热
Shure: Today should be even hotter than yesterday.
Alice:还是充电宝
Alice: Or the power bank.
Shure: 我觉得保持点距离
Shure: I think keeping some distance is better.
Katrina: 对我也感觉
Katrina: Yeah, I feel the same.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 如果我也头疼怎么办
Katrina: What if I get a headache too?
Jake:那那不用保持距离
Jake: Then you don't need to keep distance.
Jake:那我们跟你保持距离
Jake: We'll keep distance from you.
Jake:跟你们俩保持距离
Jake: From you two.
Katrina: 我昨天真的是
Katrina: Yesterday, I really...
Katrina: 要么就是不能加那个青提还是怎么的
Katrina: Maybe it was the green grapes or something.
Alice:怎么没充电宝
Alice: Why is there no power bank?
Jake:充电宝可能有吧
Jake: There might be a power bank, probably.
Lucia:让我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Jake:充电宝 拔吧拔吧
Jake: Take out the power bank.
Jake:咱也
Jake: And we...
Katrina: 那我直接算钱算了
Katrina: Then I'll just calculate the money directly.
Katrina: 就不给他发订单截图
Katrina: I won't send him the order screenshot.
Shure: 杨老板太大气
Shure: Jake, you're so generous.
Shure: 后来 杨老板像 多多财运
Shure: Later, Jake seemed to have more fortune.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha:他
Tasha: He...
Shure: 他老板说他请的助手还混了
Shure: His boss said the assistant he hired messed up.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahaha.
Shure: 但杨老板你看我给你省了500块钱房屋装修费
Shure: But Jake, I saved you 500 yuan on renovation costs.
Jake:哎那确实那确实
Jake: Yeah, that's true.
Tasha:省怎么省呢
Tasha: How did you save it?
Lucia:他没装修啊
Lucia: He didn't do any renovation.
Jake:省成这样省成这样
Jake: Saved it like this, saved it like this.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 那咱是不是省了吗
Shure: So we saved it, right?
Jake:省啊省啊
Jake: Saved it, saved it.
Shure: 就是因为我本来
Shure: Because originally...
Tasha:你就说花的值不值吗值
Tasha: You just say if it's worth spending or not. Worth it.
Jake:值  哈哈哈
Jake: Worth it. Hahaha.
Shure: 就是数据集这要保证多样性
Shure: The dataset must ensure diversity.
Shure: 就是有人需要装修有人不需要
Shure: Some people need renovation, some don't.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Shure: 你下次给我住毛坯房就行
Shure: Next time, just let me live in an unfinished house.
Shure: 只要工资到位
Shure: As long as the salary is good.
Tasha:给给
Tasha: Sure, sure.
Shure: 倒挂着住也没关系
Shure: Even if I live upside down, it's fine.
Tasha:住那个
Tasha: Live in that...
Jake:那行下次就这么定了
Jake: Okay, let's decide it like this next time.
Tasha:那个8块钱一天的那个
Tasha: That 8 yuan a day one.
Jake:啊富塞倒碑塔
Jake: Ah, upside-down tower.
Lucia:你这个研究逐渐变态在下去要塞道去了
Lucia: Your research is getting perverted, you're going to get stuck.
Shure: 因塞道那是什么鬼
Shure: What the heck is "stuck"?
Shure: 我要倒立
Shure: I need to do a handstand.
Shure: 怎么着也得500一天吧
Shure: It should be at least 500 a day, right?
Tasha:我靠那还是让他住房吧
Tasha: Wow, then let him have a proper place to stay.
Shure: 我比房子都贵
Shure: I'm more expensive than the house.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina:  董叉叉问我什么时候离开
Katrina: Jack asked me when I'm leaving.
Jake: 问你什么时候离开
Jake: He asked when you are leaving.
Katrina:  他说靖康应该要在你们后收拾东西
Katrina: He said Jingkang should pack up after you guys.
Katrina:  他他是不是要过来帮忙
Katrina: Is he coming over to help?
Katrina:  所以他要协调自己的时间是吗
Katrina: So he needs to coordinate his time, right?
Jake: 他可能是吧
Jake: Maybe he is.
Jake: 他为什么不问我呢
Jake: Why didn't he ask me directly?
Tasha:我哈哈哈
Tasha: Haha, good point.
Katrina:  有道理哈
Katrina: Makes sense, haha.
Katrina:  我要帮他看一下
Katrina: I should help him check.
Katrina:  卧槽这这小狐狸真就没了
Katrina: Oh my gosh, the little fox is really gone.
Lucia: 哎 我靠
Lucia: Oh, damn.
Shure: 好我可以订酒店了
Jake: 吃个西瓜压压惊
Jake: Let's eat some watermelon to calm down.
Tasha: 谁下呢哈哈哈
Tasha: Who's next? Haha.
Shure: 怎么抖了呢杨老板你手
Shure: Why are your hands shaking, Jake?
Shure: 我26 27
其他人：我28去 27去
Shure:  28
Shure:  去杭州
其他人：我也不知道
其他人：因为我我我比你早
其他人： 吧我我有点搞不清楚
其他人：哎就是他那个展会
其他人：有有有胸卡超级帅
其他人：都不到一周了
Shure: 花了有多少钱
Shure: 这次没没记错手机号码
Shure: 很高级
Katrina: 我另一个同学的那个
Shure: 如果你不能考上第28
Shure: 陪我玩你真的要连喝3天吗
其他人：哇但是很难得的展台
其他人：虽然每年都有
其他人：但是很难得的展台
Jake:什么东西呀
Jake: What's that?
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: 好惨呢
Shure: So miserable.
Alice:这窗帘真的很像婚纱的质地啊
Alice: These curtains really feel like wedding dress material.
Alice:所以做婚纱为什么不能用窗帘
Alice: So why can't wedding dresses be made from curtains?
Lucia: 可能说亲肤吧哈哈
Lucia: Maybe for comfort, haha.
Tasha: 可能用的是一块布
Tasha: Maybe it's the same fabric.
Tasha: 但是为了显肤
Tasha: But for showing skin.
Alice: 我以为他走了
Alice: I thought he left.
Lucia: 洗一下
Lucia: Wash it.
Alice:有一股工厂的味
Alice: Smells like a factory.
Lucia: 对 新的这些布料
Lucia: Yeah, new fabrics.
Lucia: 没事 不用洗了
Lucia: It's fine, no need to wash.
Alice: 让刘婷拿着玩吧
Alice: Let Liu Ting play with it.